une famine aux proportions bibliques
voici la menace qui plane sur le monde
dommage collatéral de la pandémie de
coronavirus cet avertissement sévère est
lancé par david beasley directeur
exécutif du programme alimentaire
mondial
le pam selon lui les dégâts économiques
et la désorganisation du à la pandémie
pourrait causer davantage de morts que
le virus lui même
en avril dernier déjà ce représentant de
l'onu de tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
comme le nouveau rapport mondial sur les
crises alimentaires publié aujourd'hui
le montre 135 millions de personnes sont
éprouvés par la faim ou pire
ceci veut dire que 135 millions de
personnes arrivent au seuil de la famine
mais maintenant à l'analyse du programme
alimentaire mondial montre qu'à cause du
coronavirus 130 millions de personnes
supplémentaires pour est elle aussi se
retrouver au bord de la famine d'ici la
fin 2001 cela fait un total de 265
millions de personnes
david beasley a encore réitéré son
avertissement le 22 août
dans une interview accordée à l'agencé
de presse russe tass toutes les données
que nous avons y compris celle du
programme alimentaire mondial indique
que le nombre de personnes qui souffrent
de malnutrition va augmenter de 80 %
d'ici à la fin de l'année les tensions
sociales vont s'accroître
l émigration se multiplier les conflits
vont escalader et la fin sera à même
d'affecter des gens qui ne l'avait pas
expérimenté jusqu'à lors lo n'diaye
oxfam avait elle aussi alerté en juillet
dernier concernant les répercussions de
la pandémie sur la faim dans le monde
pourquoi la famine guette tél
parce que les restrictions de
circulation perturbent
l'approvisionnement et les circuits de
distribution
l'accès aux denrées est bloquée et à
cause de la crise économique
les populations n'ont plus suffisamment
d'argent pour acheter de la nourriture
les personnes les plus affectées vivent
dans les pays en conflit
on compte parmi elles les déplacés et
les réfugiés
le pam estime que la proportion des
personnes mal nourries pourrait
augmenter de 2 169% en amérique latine
de 135% en asie centrale et du sud est
de 90% en afrique du sud
de nombreuses manifestations on tue
dieu par exemple en colombie au chili ou
en argentine pour protester contre la
menace de crise de la fin où la pandémie
de la faim selon l'expression de david
beasley risque-t-elle de se développer
et bien la carte redessine c'est les
crises humanitaires et des conflits au
soudan du sud
le programme alimentaire mondial et des
cinq millions de personnes il doit en
compter 1,6 million supplémentaire au
bangladesh
huit cent soixante mille réfugiés
rohingyas dépendent de cette aide pour
survivre au yémen le chiffre s'élève à
13 millions de personnes selon le pam
l'afghanistan la république démocratique
du congo la syrie le zimbabwe et
d'autres pays d'afrique de l'est risque
d'être gravement affectées et depuis le
4 août le liban aussi est concerné en
effet la double explosion dans le port
de beyrouth a notamment détruit des
stocks de céréales le port était aussi
le point de transbordement de 60 % de la
nourriture des libanais david beasley
explique toutefois que la famille n'a
pas encore frappé
mais selon lui il faut investir
d'urgence près de 5 milliards de dollars
ces six prochains mois pour sauver la
vie de millions de personnes dans 83
pays